can you at least help us make sure
mobius gets on a jet ski at some point
in time in season two
that's all i want right now
hi kate how are you i'm good thank you
yeah
just enjoying the reaction to the finale
and
yeah it's just been such a thrill
well i absolutely truly loved loki
it is not just my favorite marvel disney
plus series now but just my favorite
disney plus series at
all what do i and the fans have to do to
convince you to come back for season two
because you crushed it it was just that
it was amazing yeah
it i think for me it's like not an easy
decision it's just honestly that
when i started i always plan you know
like it was always six episodes and i
i poured everything in my soul as i'm
sure people have seen
yeah and like i'm so happy i got to work
with marvel and i hope we do again
and i just i'm so proud of all the work
we did but i just feel like this is my
bit
for this part anyway of loki's story i
feel like it's done and
yeah and i'm very proud of the work we
did and i'm i'm really excited to see
where they take season two though and
yeah nothing but
love and respect for everyone involved
and i'm i'm really excited for what
fresh eyes will bring as well
so yeah and you
truly it was a great great series that
ending was
amazing to me you it did really seem
like you poured just everything into it
so
thank you so much for that right away
can you at least help
us make sure mobius gets on a jet ski at
some point in time in season two
that's all i want right now it's been so
funny so funny because like me and the
team like marvel and the writer just
talking about it because they're like
man people like we definitely missed the
trick not getting him onto a jet ski
people
but i've seen some amazing cosplay of
two i think the loki and
its cosplayers like they were both from
a jet ski together which was incredible
but um yeah it was very cool i recommend
checking it out i probably could
have to yeah i'm gonna have to
i can't miss that that's gonna be
awesome well i hope we get to see that
um
now that loki is out and you've you know
taken some time away from it and you've
watched it you've seen the reactions
is there anything that perhaps looking
back on it that you wish you had
included or
executed differently or maybe something
that was deleted that wasn't included in
it
do you know what i would say no only
because like
i i just feel like you know we all work
very hard on the story
and there's always so much more road to
travel right like you know sylvie
we've scratched the surface on like
what's her background like where
what was it like growing up in these
apocalypses like you know we see her as
a child but then we join her as an adult
and there's this big
bit in the middle of her life that we
don't get to dig into and i think
there's just so much that i i'm really
proud of honestly we had to cut a few
scenes but
that kind of is the nature of filmmaking
you know like you you collect all this
stuff together and then you almost
rebuild it again in the edit and then
sometimes
stuff i mean we had a scene in episode
one that was funny in the memories with
loki but
it just was so near figure and it didn't
feel like it was giving that respect
the right way so we took that out but
yeah but honestly i just yeah i'm really
happy with how the story
shaped up but i yeah i like it
no i i think everybody really loved it i
i don't think i've seen
bad reviews for at all like at all i
i think everybody's pretty much on cloud
nine with you right now just about how
great it was so again thank you
to you and the whole entire team um you
know you mentioned sylvie i really want
to talk about
loki and sylvie because i love their
chemistry together
sophie and tom uh tom hiddleston of
course is so charming
and sophie brought that as well and it
seemed like sylvie was really
really the only one who kind of truly
had an impact on loki
besides his mother of course and it just
seems like there's a lot
there to be explored as well so even
though you're not coming back for season
two is there something you would like to
see
explored with the two of them them get
together stay apart
conquer worlds together anything you'd
personally like to see happen
oh for me personally i couldn't say to
be honest because like
you know i loved i can speak for the
moments in the show like i just
i love that moment with them outside the
barber shop you know and loki almost
seems a little bit
tongue-tied in places and i remember
talking to tom about on the day and i
don't think i've ever
seen loki tongue tied he has an answer
for everything but
it was so interesting to see his
character
you know like everyone right if you have
a crush it's like
you know i mean and i think it was fun
to kind of exactly to see that kind of
like oh i don't know how to do this and
and with sylvia it was just so sad you
know and she's like i know i don't have
friends
i don't even have to do this and i think
for me i always think about sylvie
particularly episode six
like where loki is in thought you know
she's driven by rage
and revenge and it's coming from a very
very dark place and
i think that's what was so sad about it
is that she's just not quite
where he is yet or you know but her
journey could be completely different
because as she
says at the very end i'm not you sorry
so i think that was always really
interesting to explore with them both
but no
i i love seeing that you know tom's loki
that the first episode he wants the
throne
and by episode 6 he's like i just want
you to be okay and it's
like almost going from a very selfish
act to a very selfless one which itself
feels like love right so
right yeah well and that's something
that i was actually genuinely curious to
see
um in the in the series because i
thought well you know our the look that
we saw died in infinity war
he went through so much to become let's
say that good person that he was at the
end and i thought
how what are they going to do to make
you know loki
that good you know in the series but i
mean executed phenomenally so
again congratulations on that um you
know i think i read an interview once
that said
you you know probably about halfway into
season one you figured out that there
was going to be a season two
and you know you did that cliffhanger at
the end was there originally an
ending planned for season one where it
kind of wrapped up
no i we basically i think that's the
thing we were always in a state of like
evolution and like when i joined you
know like
the writers had crafted that you know
loki and sylvia would go to end of time
and they would go to the citadel and
they would meet he who remains
and we didn't know exactly how at that
point but we knew the multiverse would
like
come out of this and that's how that's
how it would end
so that was always kind of the ending we
were working towards the ending i would
say we didn't have
set in stone yet was obviously loki
going back to this other tva
and that twist and that came in later
and
i think also just in terms of the season
two of it all just the mid-credits
because
we never really built in like mid
credits for the show
interestingly and it's obvious such an
amazing marvel staple
having like a little tease at the end in
the whole team we're like oh where can
we put these and like um
episode four for example used to go
straight from the time theater to loki
waking up
and i remember being like oh actually in
the in the edit with my editor emma i
was like oh let's move it
so it's mid-credit because if i was
watching it i'd be like they just killed
loki
they just went and did it of course
again so
i just thought okay well that'll be
really satisfying and then also it's all
the more satisfying because then he
wakes up and it's like the amazing
variant of himself so that felt like a
really fun
mid-credits there and i felt like oh
that's really fun to give that nod to
that amazing mob or kind of you know the
thing they do
but then for episode six it again felt
like kind of a cool way to do it to
announce the second season as well
because again
it's the final episode right and it's
almost like thing at the end of the
marvel movie and you're just waiting for
that you know tease kind of scene so
again it felt like the appropriate place
to put that as well
yeah and what a great you know for us
who didn't know like what a great
surprise
for a season two the season one was
phenomenal i wish you had more time to
talk because i'd ask you so many more
questions
but uh i'll just say that i truly did
love loki thank you so much for that
thanks so much for the work that you put
into it and direction
uh it was lovely i enjoyed every second
of it and it was a pleasure to speak to
you today thank you kate
no thank you cheers thank you